i can remember getting on a plane and an
older white woman saying oh your son is
a gangster rapper right how did you let
him marry your daughter tina knowles
lawson is sharing a telling personal
story tina my mouth fell open when you
gave that example speaking with gayle
king on cbs mornings the mother of
beyonce and solange discussed her latest
project profiled the black man that's
the narrative i felt threatened i felt
afraid if they got on handcuffs there's
still a threat because they're a black
men the morning show aired a clip from
the upcoming docu-series where tina
described this memorable encounter i can
remember getting on a plane and older
white woman saying oh your son is a
gangster rapper right how did you let
him marry your daughter
and it was just shocking to me and i
said no actually my son is a ceo she
didn't think of him as a ceo or even a
talented celebrity that
you know was a great businessman
following the clip tina shared what she
took away from the experience at that
time i remember thinking you know i
can't be mad at her because that is what
the media portrays tina my mouth fell
open when you gave that example because
i'm thinking and then you followed up by
saying i'm not even mad at her
how are you not mad you know i sat there
and i thought about how the media
portrays
black men and how
that is typical of the things that they
would focus on uneducated gangster
rapper that's all she could come up with
tina hopes her new project helps debunk
these damaging stereotypes so if we can
kind of get people to understand that
that's not so and to show them examples
of otherwise that we are we do have good
fathers and we are good providers and we
love our you know our men love their own
women as well um it's just all the
negative stereotype
and and it's
it's just perpetuated over and over
no matter what yeah it it's just what
everybody thinks i want to ask you about
jay-z's album i think his genius is i
mean like all of his projects i thought
it was really great tina is always quick
to praise jaycee while chatting with e.t
it's a family night and i'm just so
excited i'm so proud of my son-in-law in
november tina showed her support at the
premiere of the harder they fall i mean
i cannot wait to see this movie i know
with the cast that's in it that they're
going to kill it and it's just an
important story to be told jay-z
produced the star-studded western
[Music]
the rapper said he and tina always know
what's most important the family out
tonight is a family affair i saw your
mother-in-law so proud of you yeah yeah
we're going we yeah we support each
other